[Musique]
le roi arthur revient c'est super si la
ferme mais si cette classe notre mission
commentant la table ans la barbe et
m'appeler bassir camelot premier volet
bon on fait quoi ben on commence par les
trois connards peut-être
c'est nous les trois connards au cinéma
le 21 juillet
le roi arthur vient
si on fait débat salle je sais pas ce
que vous ferez y aurait moyen de réduire
la voilure sur la connerie il veut dire
ça dans le bon sens du terme
camelot premier volet vous faites deux
cent pas sur le chemin et vous monter la
garde au cas où quelqu'un approche
approche son chemin
vous faites deux cent pas sur le chemin
et vous monter la garde et si la
personne qui approchent suprend revient
non vous monter la garde
au cinéma le 21 juillet
le roi arthur vient disant qu'on a plus
vu son pif il est khan et le fiston
drague on le sait tous jetés
hallucinations à cause de la diète
évidemment qu'il est pas mort ça fait
dix ans que je vous dis qu'on sacrifie
bon dieu par tous les saints
la malade a commencé pas je suis
absolument pas royer pas besoin de se
lever camelot premier volet qu'est ce
que vous entendez exactement pas vous
êtes de retour dès fois que vous
redevenir war voilà maintenant si vous
le sentez pas où ils sont et pas
au cinéma le 21 juillet
et le roi arthur vient vous êtes de
retour et ça c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle pour nous tous bien sûr mais
surtout pour le peuple breton qui arme a
commencé sérieusement tire la langue
c'est à dire c'est métaphorique petit il
tire pas littéralement tous la langue
sont au bout du rouleau quoi
séparé n'était pas c'est pas
littéralement un gros rouleau avec des
jambes camelot premier volet voyons
maintenant si vous ne sentez pas vous ne
sentez pas au cinéma le 21 juillet